à la une de ce 13 février bien nous
sommes lundi et ça se voit ça c'est de
l'anarchie c'est du
totalitarisme pardon
nous sommes lundi car le livre bien sûr
vous ne pouvez pas arriver ici et me
dire que la suppression des CHSCT n'a eu
aucun effet ce sont 150 orphelins d'œuf
veuves en plus et vous avez la
responsabilité de cette choix politique
vous êtes un imposteur et un assassin
mais ce nouveau dérapage verbal a
provoqué une suspension de séance j'ai
eu il y a quelques instants à ce micro
des mots que l'émotion et l'emportement
m'ont fait mal choisir
et qui sont déplacés je souhaite
évidemment les retirer et adresser des
excuses publiques au ministre et je me
tiens à sa disposition pour avoir un
échange plus personnel et lui présenter
à nouveau mes excuses les leaders
syndicaux sont de plus en plus agacés
par la mauvaise pièce jouer à
l'Assemblée ça ne fait pas grandir la
République et ça ne nourrit pas la
cohésion sociale de notre républicain un
spectacle lamentable on aurait dit le
plateau d'un moulin quoi c'est
l'Assemblée nationale ça mérite de la
dignité si t'es pas bien en ce moment
c'est pas la peine de faire arrête de
dire
ça je te le dis je te le dis t'as pas
les mêmes cheveux que lui tu n'as pas
tout ça donc redescendre deux étages et
quand je te dis calme c'est calme c'est
ici il y a un chef d'orchestre donc tu
es plein pipi voilà un chef d'orchestre
aussi pareil quand je te dis calme c'est
calme ok terminé ah d'accord je suis un
gars voilà Fanny
les débats l'Assemblée en ce moment
c'est 50 % de ça de brouhaha total
[Applaudissements]
monsieur pickman je me sens pas du tout
représenté quand je vois le comportement
qu'ils ont et pire je me sens pas
considéré parce que je me dis qu'en fait
on n'est pas assez important pour qu'il
se tienne correctement pour qu'il
débattent correctement qu'il se laisse
travailler entre eux parce qu'en fait
quand il y a un chat hypermanent et un
brouhaha permanent en fait tu peux
vraiment pas te concentrer donc on est
pas de nous assez important pour qu'il
se tienne correctement et sur justement
sur ce que je disais un peu attardé quoi
là j'ai moyen de l'assemblée et de 49
ans maintenant voici l'âge moyen
ressenti
du violon ou du pipeau je viens de
recevoir des injures d'une de mes
collègues il a
une forme d'animation de sadiste de
l'hémicycle moi je vous invite à écouter
par exemple un rappeur comme sch il dit
se lever pour 1200 euros c'est un dessin
je finirai en paraphrasant un autre
rappeur Jul qui dit personne ne veut
soulever des palettes tout le monde veut
sa retraite on fera l'apéro tout à
l'heure
apéro il veut faire l'apéro avant le
petit déj
[Applaudissements]
c'est insupportable vous ne servez
strictement à rien les Français ne sont
pas dupe de votre perfidie lundi vous
m'avez dit tais-toi la vieille
4 ans et demi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis 25 ans ce qui a changé la vie des
gens c'est les applications c'est les
téléphones portables c'est le progrès
technologique bien sûr et l'avancée
société
c'est quoi ou un gouvernement c'est
quelqu'un qui non c'est quelqu'un qui me
prend des taxes ou qui fait des skis qui
met des radars voilà ce que c'est au
aujourd'hui
si les personnages d'Harry Potter
étaient des femmes et hommes politiques
ce n'est pas un internaute lambda qui
est à l'origine de ses tweets mais le
groupe Renaissance qui a tout supprimé
depuis au casting on trouvait Marine Le
Pen en méchant Voldemort Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en mini geniarde l'éléphantome
qui entre l'école de Poudlard Marine Le
Pen était notamment comparé à Voldemort
alors au niveau des idées c'est un peu
caricatural mais visuellement c'est
carrément bien vu et Sandrine Rousseau
en mandragore une plante réputée pour
ses cris forcément le parti présidentiel
s'était réservé les beaux rôles
Dumbledore le directeur respecté
revenait à Emmanuel Macron et la bonne
et la vermione à Elisabeth borne quant
aux personnages principal le sorcier
héros Harry Potter et bien il était
attribué à Stéphane séjourné secrétaire
général du parti et alors ils ont aussi
comparé Elisabeth borne a Hermione
Granger ce qui n'est absolument aucun
sens parce que tout le monde sait
qu'Elizabeth borne c'est le professeur
McGonagall
messieurs tu as un petit check
bon bravo à vous tous et ça fait un peu
Power Rangers
sur Tik Tok des vidéos comme celle-ci
cumulent plus d'un million de vues
des tutoriels pour se créer des
cicatrices sur le visage en se pinçant
très fort avec les doigts
une tendance dangereuse que connaissent
ces collégiens je trouve que c'est
débile de se faire des cicatrices enfin
vraiment faut suivre les autres et ça
sert à rien le but ce serait ainsi de
ressembler à un pirate on espère que ce
défi s'arrêtera quand les ados
comprendront que le seul pirate auquel
ils peuvent ressembler visiblement c'est
un pirate adepte de la bifle je pense
franchement ça n'est pas un vieux
correctionnaire pour anticiper sur la
réaction
d'Étienne que d'être consterné par ce
phénomène de mode et de se dire que ces
jeunes quand même auraient beaucoup
mieux à faire donc moi je suis pour
l'augmentation du temps de travail que
les jeunes à l'école au collège au lycée
je pense que tous ces branleurs doivent
être remis dans le droit chemin si c'est
un jeu d'enfant pour Olivier pour notre
patron ce n'est pas si évident
je suis désolé
mais je les ai retenu tu as de la chance
c'est dur
parce que tu vois c'est pas bien tombé
t'inquiète pas il y a pas de problème
parce que là c'est pas tombé fort dans
la cour de récré nous on jouait le jeu
du bureau avec un paquet de cigarettes
avec quelqu'un avait le bout avait une
ceinture et si le paquets de cigarettes
tombaient pas droit le bourreau te
donnait des coups de ceinture sur la
main voilà on faisait on jouait avec ça
au collège
justement pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière dans un cabinet